all right neither red background they
have not even in this game injustice -
phone justice - is the sequel to
injustice gods among us and next
fighting game from NetherRealm Studios
the makers of Mortal Kombat the DC
fighting game in the vein of Mortal
Kombat - the fatality that the makers of
Mortal Kombat take fatalities out of
their fighting game they better make it
cool they did last time they did this
time first let's talk about the story of
injustice - all right so injustice gods
among us the story was through a
slippery slope of very good intention
Superman has become a tyrant so Batman
devises a plan to take him out with
other heroes from another universe the
whole multiverse DC comic book bang it's
rail so now it's been some years after
that this new threat called Brainiac he
shows up on earth he's bad news of the
dilemma is ll whim I need Superman help
Supergirl she's new to earth really a
lot of the story is seen through her
eyes she's like oh kal-el is my cousin
oh he's kind of a dick that's what I
really loved what they did with the
story in here because it since it's been
some years since the first injustice
some of the heroes who went bad in the
first game they're still bad some of the
heroes who were bad in the first game
have turned good some of the villains
that turn good there's a lot of moments
where someone's like I'm good now please
trust me and someone else is like we
don't care a lot of moments of tension
really if you look at it this is DC's
Civil War only it's not this ambiguous
or like well both sides could be right
for perspective now Superman is clearly
the bad guy now these General Zod so the
humor or Superman is good is to humor
General Zod is good which I've heard
people do is just interesting they took
Superman in that direction the graphics
in this game not only are the graphics
great for a fighting game when you're
watching the cutscenes the
cinematography I was looking at it was
like this is every bit a movie as a
movie could be and he's a good cast of
heroes in a fighting game like this
you're going to have your main flagship
characters and you're going to have
characters we're kind of secondary
characters the really hardcore fans
might know them you might know them if
you saw the flash TV show not everyone's
going to know them the first game had
that they've changed some of the
characters out for new one I think the
cast in this game is really well thought
out really well put together there's 9
DLC characters to come later on do you
think NetherRealm Studios are taking
requests like if I say please have John
Constantine and injustice to you think
they're going to listen they're probably
I really want John conferencing and
really if you had a character in the
first game that you really loved they
didn't alter your character too much a
couple tweaks here and there totally get
their going to do that in an T fighting
game but really the essence of what that
character did like if you were thrashing
it with Batman and injustice one you can
pick up Batman in this game and crush it
as Batman which is kind of a bummer
because people are going to fight online
like alright everyone's new to the game
right now missus aerelon you might get
your balls kicked in online as the way
it's going to be but nothing's more
infuriating to win a fighting game you
have that character in the first game
you're like yeah I'm so good I can't
wait to play as that character in the
next game and they change everything
about them they didn't pull a Tekken
what was at four or five word Paul
Phoenix I'm like he doesn't even fight
like him anymore the little tweaks in
the game player like among the clashes
the clashes are back in the last game
they would clash bounce back and say
something to each other and then run at
each other this one the clash happens
very face-to-face it's very close and I
was like oh looks like it's going to
slow the game down not when you're in it
laughter no clash you never feel like
this game loses momentum ever and
especially was oh my god the super moves
he has yes they're back and then we
think my favorite has got to be the
flash watch a YouTube video of the
Flash's super move from injustice to the
big thing in this game is gear I was
really pumped to be farming gear as also
a little apprehensive and scared about
gear but I love about gear is you now
get something for all your hard work
you're grinding you're doing the fight
you're playing the multiverse Hey look
at that you've got a new chess piece for
Supergirl we got a new head piece for
the Joker you have people who didn't
like the Joker's character designed it's
fine you can get different hair for the
Joker and make him look like a more
streamlined Joker that you may or may
not be familiar with the fact that the
Joker's even in this game there's no
reason for him to be in this game he's
not actually in the story at all he's in
one vision that Harley gets but that's
it why is the Joker in this game because
it's a DC fighting game and the Joker is
in DC this is the most recognizable and
famous comic book villain of all time
you have a fighting game you better have
that dude in it so they did it's as
simple as that that you have a minute
because he's the Joker
not only does gear give you different
stat buffs but it makes you look it
makes your character look so different
every time you go up against a character
in any multiverse fight or latter fight
they look completely different than the
last time you fought that the
possibilities truly are endless when it
comes to that and as much as I love
opening the boxes getting a good loot
explosion of gear I love me
here grind the thing that was a little
frayed I was with some of the Kier look
so over-the-top and crazy I was bred
like my flash would look something like
that Play Arts Kai flash I think I don't
need that I like playing as the flash
from certain properties I love the
variety but there is a part of me that
hopes that they get gear from different
properties like they'll be awesome if
the Joker got his Killing Joke
shorts Killing Joke shirt Killing Joke
head The Killing Joke gear and you piece
all the gear together because there is
gear that works in tandem with each
other like oh you have all three pieces
of that gear set here's a nubuck it be
cool if they had gear sets that are
actually from official DC property so
far I haven't seen it shoot maybe you
guys have I just haven't so right now
it's on the wish list or at least the
hopeless but it does keep pushing me
anytime you get some really cool piece
of epic gear it's like oh that's for
your Superman level 12
you're like my Superman level 11 they
always give you really good gear like
Rare gear or a figure that's a couple
levels higher than the character you
have forcing you to play as that
character thus be able to equip it and
the next piece of gear will be a couple
levels it's like dangling and carrot in
front of you you look like going after
it darn good tasty carrot what you get
it so I've mentioned the multiverse I
better talk about the multiverse
multiverse it's a single-player mode in
injustice 2 where I think the towers in
mortal combat acts how they change out
like ones every it's a daily tower the
other ones a weekly tower the other ones
like every couple hours like that but
more worlds one of those like three days
that world will go in one day that one
will go away and a couple hours that one
will go away in about an hour and a half
that one will go away and in each of
these worlds is a tower where you beat
that you get a piece of Epicure for this
character you beat the other one get
another prize another random loot box of
gear but if you do all the logistics and
clear that world out you get something
cool a platinum box a piece of gear or
something and these things are
constantly changing out further change
out time which gives you every reason to
go back I'm telling you this is the most
fun I've ever had playing single-player
in a fighting game ever that's the thing
about me like my friends don't really
play a lot of injustice from Mortal
Kombat Mortal Kombat X I was pretty
savage online I'm not going to lie I'm
better at Mortal Kombat than I am in
justice so a lot of the times I'm forced
to play injustice by myself yeah there
are different worlds with different
logistics that gives me gear you're not
just doing it for a little border around
your profile those little profile is
doing this but no you get gear for
characters now I can't stress how
monumentally game-changing that is for a
fighting game like this you thought you
loved the towers of Mortal Kombat X
you're never going to leave your couch
with injustice to
thank you bye to everything goodbye to
your job goodbye to your girlfriend
they're never going to see you again
here you're there you are well as I said
there are nine DLC characters coming out
or DLC it's a fact of life at this point
but I feel that injustice too has done
their part to minimize the
microtransactions I haven't actually run
across anything in this game that you
can buy that you can't earn through
gameplay make sure everyone is not pay
too when you can't just buy gear you
have to farm it but you can go on the
PlayStation Network and buy these coins
and it lets you unlock costume shaders
alternate costumes for other characters
that make them other characters or you
can just actually play the game unlock
those coins anyway through gameplay then
unlock these gifts which is what I've
been doing it's what I have to do
because I need this needs to be
positively reinforced when you have fans
that they're bitching about the fact
that game companies like oh you want
that Garrett well you got to pay for it
and it's like how many fighting games
have I reviewed where I've just been
like why don't we go back to a time
where gameplay unlocks the gear now we
here it is they're doing that and even
though I'm buying the coins to unlock
certain things in this game does exist
nothing has a gun to your head saying
you have to buy it you can play the game
to unlock it if you'd like which is what
I do I'm totally cool with other people
being able to buy their way into
unlocking [ __ ] I just don't want to do
that so here I am having fun unlocking
[ __ ] through gameplay the Captain Cold
is in this game you get enough coins you
can unlock a variant suit of his which
makes him mr. freeze all the character
dialogue with him use mr. freeze like
everything I do I do for Nara and I
unlocked that because I played enough of
a game to unlock that it felt awesome as
I feel like I hadn't felt that in a
fighting game it's so long unlocking
characters through gameplay just it's
almost new though very old although I
haven't seen any way to get Darkseid in
this game other than pre-ordering it
again stuff that is a thing in here and
it's a bummer I don't know people are
going to eventually get Darkseid for
free all I know is right now he's a
pre-order bonus I don't like that but
time will tell
to see how that's managed and how that's
handled there is one of the worlds in
the multiverse where you can play as
Darkseid I'm like I'm not really missing
out I'm not that great with Darkseid
guys in the end injustice 2 is a proper
sequel to injustice gods among us and a
very expected follow through to the step
up that NetherRealm Studios always does
with their games injustice 2 steps it up
from injustice gods among us and every
by possible and injustice to is awesome
tacular alright guys so injustice to
have you played it what did you think
about it or have you read the comic
books do you like the injustice
storyline are you going to pick this one
out are you going to youtube the
cutscenes whatever you think whatever
you've done whatever you're going to do
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]